YOU KNOW, I THINK IT'S TIME FOR
A SEGMENT I LIKE TO CALL WORD
BLERD.
>> WORD BLERD!
( LAUGHTER ).
>> Larry: NOW, BACK IN MY DAY
A SLUT WAS WHAT YOU CALLED A
GIRL WHO DEVELOPED FASTER THAN
YOU BOTH PHYSICALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY.
SHE DABBLED IN HEALTHY SEXUAL
EXPERIMENTATION WHICH WAS
INTIMIDATING, OR SHE REFUSED TO
HAVE SEX WITH YOU, WHICH WAS
FRUSTRATING.
( LAUGHTER )
AND SO TO PUNISH HER FOR MAKING
YOU FEEL BAD, YOU CALLED HER A
SHUT THAT'S WHAT THAT WORD IS
USED FOR.
IT DOES NOT APPLY TO ANY
13-YEAR-OLD BASEBALL PLAYER YOU
WANT TO TRASH ON THE INTERNET.
THE ONLY THING MO'NE DAVIS IS
SLUTTY WITH, IS HER FASTBALL.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
BOYS ALL AROUND TOWN LINE UP FOR
IT.
SHE GIVES IT TO EVERY ONE OF
THEM.
AND EVEN WITH THAT IN MIND, YOU
CAN'T REALLY EVEN CALL HER A
SLUT, BECAUSE VERY FEW OF THE
GUYS SHE MEETS EVER MAKE IT TO
HOME BASE.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
THIS HAS BEEN WORD BLERD.
>> WORD BLERD!